yeah you know welcome to this video this
is a good one playing an adaptation
that's Grandmaster Fabiano Caruana
so I'm playing one of the top players in
the world that's cool
he's playing the Trump let's see what he
does against this line the line
suggested by Boris of rope in his
repertoire box a super solid
continuation okay I remember that I had
problems with an early Queen b3 so I'm
going to clarify the situation here
Queen a4 okay I think taking probably
Bishop d6 should be okay Bishop d6
Bishop b5 set a problem Bishop d6 95 you
know I don't think so
okay so I think I'll just cancel him
okay so I don't want to take on g3 now
I'll give him the open age file but okay
maybe a bishop age four can be a move
it's not a big K Queen c7 bishop age
form might be a problem maybe just this
okay now I can I can take and okay yes
got a possible Knight e5 coming do I
want to go 97 I'm not sure about it but
I can't ready myself for that move and
maybe e5 at the right moment
possible queen f form okay
hmm see going back now maybe to age two
or something
mm-hmm okay five or am i opening up the
position I mean more and in his more in
his favor
that's what I'm trying to say hmm
yeah I Scott working I can't repair you
five okay but that also has its
drawbacks
it's that is it that great here for him
something I'd love to do get a Knight to
e4 of course but Knight to f6 that other
night maybe here night at cat6 the only
thing is that might all be a bit too
slow
oh tactics 94 oh very nice now okay that
was that was nice
my queen is trapped my queen is trapped
he's got an idea for next okay I let it
play him out I'm a communist who it was
squares okay that's a bit of a shame
that it is a known game against such a
good opponent okay I have to resign
black resigns
I came so I have to do something else so
what do I have to do a g5 is a threat
some Knight b6 something like that yeah
okay that idea of g5 is pretty strong
maybe this wasn't wasn't a really good
idea here or I have to improve him
I was thinking e5 maybe I was my first
thought using my
decent development I wasn't sure about
this move here engine just wants to take
the form says I'm okay I was thinking of
this more but I didn't like this here
the engine agrees I mean yeah I think I
have I have a decent position I mean
this is what the computer wants to just
do this check check
well that's not so easy for you and
player to play I'm currently a little
bit pinned here the computers line is
there special back g6 bishop here Queen
here then right over here yeah that that
is definitely not bad at all the engines
evaluation is equal it's probably true
maybe that's what I have to do I wanted
to prepare you five with rookie aid so
that there's not this pin anymore but
this is now already getting getting
tricky because that that g5 is is
dangerous
37 of course was really bad but I didn't
see the immediate g5 idea at all that
McQueen is is strapped yeah quite nice
so if I am
what can the engine wants to go g5 for
black if that is necessary I'm gonna I'm
in bad shape
it just gives 0.5 but g5 feels pretty
bad yeah it's very quick there if I play
something like that g5 Teague's this is
this is I'm sorry this
getting bad now I'm just getting killed
him okay that was a completely wrong
kind of evaluation for me that I'm that
Queen f4 and so on okay if I can we
fight I'm okay but that's something that
and it wasn't yeah maybe I played this a
little bit too passively yeah also e5 is
good it's not so easy if you have such a
strong opponent you you kind of
influenced by their it's funny okay I
hope you enjoyed the game anyway thanks
for watching